when i was a
coming up man i remember as because i'm
a die die-hard
outcast fan die hard dungeon family fan
when when you guys all came together
for uh even in darkness right i thought
that was
i mean i'm even like i remember cool or
cool breezes
east boys finest album that watch for
the hook was my [ __ ] i'm a huge dungeon
family fan so when everybody got
together and made even in darkness
it was crazy can you guys give me some
uh like a story or two
about the making of the actual dungeon
family album because
i think that that album is very slept on
and doesn't get enough
i don't hear enough conversation or
praise about how dope that project was
that's a good example man use a cool
breeze esports greatest hit
i mean that's something watch for the
hook man like you know that's when you
know his project was launched off the
back of
organized noise you know um you know
uh opening up the doors you know cutting
the ribbon on
their new label overnight those records
you know me like you know um
uh organized noise uh via
interscope you know what i'm saying so
that was that was a big
look you know i mean so we all came
together you know like
with the camaraderie with the teamwork
to make that dream work me like for the
homie you know what i mean
no different than he showed up for us
when he call in the phrase dirty south
let me like
and then did that say you feel me too uh
to to good mob's debut album so like you
mean like
you know the love is reciprocated you
know what i mean like you feel me i
always acknowledge it
where it's due i'm saying so you know
like you want no egos and then another
kind of [ __ ] let me like the whole it
was a homie term
we we we you know we chained up you know
he got suited up and got on the field
with him and that's what it was about
yeah but with the even darkness album
what was that
like that's that's a hard thing to pull
everybody together especially at that
point of everyone's careers
because you guys are all at that point
in time cast is [ __ ] out of here
and then you got freaking out of here
and to bring everyone together
what what what was i'm assuming that uh
was it organized noise that kind of
quarterbacked the creative process for
that project like
what was what was making that album like
it was organized north because i'm we
was both on tour
like outcast was doing smoking grooves
too i think goody mom was out with uh
i think we just came off uh bone and
daylight soul tour
oh [ __ ] so so it was it was it was a
real
crazy time so we was doing the records
in and out coming in and out of time
you know like so we didn't really get to
start
to even do that do that hour we didn't
get the tour
a lot because just our schedules man it
was just we was just doing so much at
that time
i can imagine um with this project
what uh what what was the
with the word survival kit i mean like
when i see that and
go ahead you know why labels don't
support big albums like that bro and why
that stuff only happened every so often
not because they don't want to see
something great you know i mean like you
know but
because logistically projects like that
are expensive to do
i'm saying it's a lot of work in parts
especially if everyone's on different
labels
different labels and different tax
brackets and pay grades contain all of
that
it takes a lot of humility from everyone
involved right
yeah yeah because like you said
there might be somebody who'd be like yo
man i'll do it but i need more than this
person and it's like
we're not doing it for that we're doing
it because anything about you having
more than that person's about i need
what i deserve
right yeah because y'all gonna turn
right back around
and promote this to my audience inside
the orders that i've earned and work for
so if you gonna send it back to them
you're gonna say like you know
at least give me yeah damn you know
right right right
what i need is that a little [ __ ]